today's guest is mr david siteman
garland of the show and website the rise
to the top and author of the newly
released book smarter faster cheaper
non-boring fluff free strategies for
marketing and promoting your business
david is an online content creator host
entrepreneur author speaker and now
consultant
his show the rise to the top
has featured the likes of movers and
shakers such as seth godin gary
vaynerchuk also known as garyvee bob
berg tony shea peter shankman tim
ferriss chris brogan the list goes on
and on and on the riots at the top is a
web show that's informative fun and is
anything but talk filled with fluff as
the site says if you want some fluff go
pet a bunny david's episodes cut right
to the chase delving into each guest's
ideas in a way that's concise energy
packed and makes you think so please
welcome to the film courage show via
skype mr david siteman garland hello
hello welcome david and karen thanks so
much for having me on i'm excited you
know it's always weird hearing yourself
even after doing this for a while you
hear the clip you're like oh who's that
guy
right we know how it is this is awesome
you know this is such a great way to
start off the new year yeah um go go to
thetweetchat.com and use the hashtag
film couriers to keep up with all the
chatter happening today um on on twitter
um you can also say hi to us on facebook
um filmcurse.com so there's a lot of
places you can sort of track the show we
do our best to get you on the air well
welcome again thank you for helping us
kick off the new year with excitement
and passion um as we begin we have a
quote that you know you've inspired uh
and we're we don't know who who actually
came up with this quote maybe you can
help us it's an unknown quote and it
reads entrepreneurship is living a few
years of your life like most people
won't so that you can spend the rest of
your life like most people can't
and it's a beautiful quote it's very
true yeah so having said that let's get
right into it the way you often do with
your show you're bursting onto the scene
with the rise to the top television show
where in the last two years you've
interviewed some of the most influential
marketers and business people in the
land and you've just released your first
book smarter faster cheaper
can you give us a snapshot of who you
are and what you're all about yeah sure
you know it's one of those crazy stories
you know when i when i was growing up
i'm from uh exotic st louis missouri
here so right right in the middle right
in the midwest and my grandpa is and i
always say was but he is he's still
alive he was a very what i would call a
traditional businessman i'm putting that
in quotes
traditional in quotes and you know i
would go to his office when i was
younger and and i was like oh i was like
this is like really boring it was you
know a lot of people walking around in
suits and just bored and there was water
coolers and i was like man this is what
business is and business kind of sucks
and that was one of my initial thoughts
when i was growing up
and after i graduated college and i i
got a taste of the real world i had no
job i had a degree in women's studies uh
which is a whole nother show right there
uh straight white male with a degree in
women's studies um
i yeah
yeah let's just pause and enjoy that
okay sure
so i i graduated school and i still
didn't have that
um business bug yet
i was still deciding what i was gonna do
i wasn't gonna become a woman that was
not part of the plan i didn't really
know what i was gonna do and i was gonna
move to actually southern california and
do marketing for a hockey rink i was big
into hockey and they said hey come on
out you can do marketing at this rank
and get your feet well and i said okay
i'll go try it and two weeks before i
moved out they called me and they said
the rink is closing and becoming a
parking lot so
don't come out to california
so i said well what am i going to do now
and what ended up happening
was i took a quote-unquote job as a
partner in a new company a startup i'd
never done a startup before um
it was a startup in st louis missouri
that was centered around the hockey
industry and it was called pro inline
hockey association so it was a
professional hockey league on wheels
coming to the midwest and they said hey
you want to come in we need someone
that's kind of young and nuts um aka
cheap uh that can come in they can come
in and help with this can you do it and
i said sure and so that's how i got my
whole entrepreneurial mba if you will
was building this pro inline hockey
league over two years and and learning
how to sign sponsorships and do
everything from cleaning bathrooms to
actually believe it or not hosting a
radio show on a local espn station here
in st louis so i tried everything over
several years um and and what the the
point of the story is i got this bug i
got the entrepreneurial bug saying man
going back to grandpa's office there's
so many people doing other things and
making a great living there's people
doing creative things and interesting
things and and things that they're
passionate about and other alternative
ways that we could not even dreamed of
of ways that they're making money and
also are extremely happy and that's when
i decided that i wanted to dedicate
myself to creating a show around telling
those stories and inspiring others to do
the same and that's how really the
entire the rise to the top concept was
born um based on really my boringness in
my grandpa's office
and how long ago did you start that so
the crazy time frame on that is the rise
to the top actually started um in the
first episode aired in october of 2008
so this was this was not something that
was 25 years ago right right and at a
very tough time
so
you launch smarter faster cheaper the
book have you done more interviews in
the past month since you've ever done or
or has this just sort of been a steady
stream and and you're used to the press
oh that's a good question you know
it's a it's interesting so the book was
book release and you know that's always
uh quite an adventure getting a book i
was my first one it's been very humbling
the response by it and it's been a lot
of fun and what i really did when the
book came out was i relied on people i
already had existing relationships with
or people that came to me or people that
i was introduced to and i just did a
massive smattering and continue to um
all kinds of different interviews
because i as you know i'm a huge
believer in the power of the interview
and i just think there's nothing more
humanizing and fun also so
i did you know i had days where i did 27
interviews in a day wow when the book
came out that was not recommended
i was like i felt like i'm not a drug
person but i felt like i couldn't even
move it was bad bad idea let's just put
it that way um but you know i love
talking to people i love sharing stories
and i love trying to help and if i can
ever do that you know i'm always trying
to make time for the press new media old
media whatever media um i i have a huge
affinity for all of it so i always try
to make time and so there was a lot in
december i pre-taped a lot of the
interviews for my show knowing that i
had to make time to do a lot of
interviews and it's been a blast
there's no question you are putting the
work in david um and we're going to
continue to talk about building your
business the community and we're just
going to keep going with it but while we
have you on the line i just want to
quickly ask do you do you watch any
independent films
i got to tell you i do
and
and this is you know it's funny i've
done a lot you know obviously like i
just mentioned a lot of interviews
lately
i was so excited about this one because
i think i have like a secret fetish for
filmmaking
like it's there and like i don't know
like maybe it's like hiding in the
closet i don't even know right you know
i love films i love going to movies i
love watching independent films um if
you start trying to have me list them i
will fail miserably but i love the film
industry in fact i would love to get
more involved in it in the in the future
in some capacity that that's how much of
just uh it really is something that i
find exciting well you know since you're
from saint louis we'd like to give a
shout out to local filmmakers matthew
krentz and patrick rooney
they made the film street ballers um
which was shot shot
shot right there in st louis um they're
great guys we've had them here on the
show they have a lot of passion very
talented so there you go some st louis
filmmakers there um what are the top
three ways that you watch movies um is
it going out to the movie theater is it
using netflix
um whatever comes on cable
yeah great question um i think you hit
the three of them uh let's see so we
like uh my fiance and i you know it's
funny because i've always been a movie
person when i was young
my mom started me on movies when i was
very very young and i'm not talking
about like cartoons like my mom wanted
always treated me like an adult even
when i was like three so
she she was she was you know we were
watching movies like overboard and
splash and those types of movies when i
was younger so i grew up really watching
movies and my fiance is less of a
moviegoer and now i'm forcing her which
is a lot of fun for everyone
i really want to go to the film
festivals and do all that kind of stuff
in the future too i'd love to figure out
a way to kind of get involved in that
community because i love it but uh we go
to
a lot of independent theaters in st
louis that's one of my favorite things
to do is like just spot random ones that
are that are really kind of a cool
experience like there's even one that
has the old organ guys like 119 or so
you know and he's like sitting there
playing the organ before the movie and
i'm like this is making me very excited
even if the movie's terrible and uh
besides that my mom for hanukkah got us
uh netflix so i've been exploring with
that and other than that you know i i'm
uh i love flipping around on television
for random movies and stuff like that
and i think that i really love
documentaries i've started to realize
and i i really really enjoy
documentaries because i like a good
story and i think that by watching those
whether it's 30 30 or 30 on espn or or
just you know the enron scandal or just
on a biography on an individual i just
love that kind of filmmaking and you
know i i think i had this secret thing
one day that i'd love to do a
documentary of some kind or be involved
in one and so maybe that's one way one
reason i watch them so much well this is
film courage we are on the line with
david siteman garland author of smarter
faster cheaper and host of the rise to
the top
in your interview with seth godin he
mentioned that the work that
scares people is really the work that
the entrepreneur the freelancer and
probably the independent artist should
really be focusing on
and he says it's easy to do a lot of
busy work such as social media and other
various things and to kind of work hard
all day and then think oh wow look what
i've accomplished
and it really it really isn't anything
tangible and i guess he calls that sort
of the the lizard brain speaking so i'm
curious what's the work that scares you
and how do you overcome the fear
and and get to the effective part of
your day yeah and that was a great you
know seth godin
personal hero of mine
a big thinker he always at he always
says stuff like that and it stops you in
your tracks and you're like oh god you
know
oh no big question from zack right
and and you know he's a little scary and
i love him uh but what's interesting
about that for me um and i i totally
agree with him i think that we often get
stuck doing a lot of things where we can
take up it's very easy to fill time uh
in many cases and another thing that he
says is shipping right so shipping is
when you're actually creating something
and getting it out to the world and
that's the way that i see it and and for
me the thing that
i think maybe it's not the scariest but
it's the thing that i enjoy shipping i
love doing these interviews i love it i
i mean i could sit here all day and do
them unless someone you know someone
would have to like wheel me to the
bathroom or something like that but i
enjoyed them so much that that my
business evolved to really allow me to
do more of them and and some of them
more quickly uh which is why i do a lot
of my video interviews via skype now but
i think that my challenge and the thing
that scares me is always going beyond
the the easy
the easy guests i don't know if that
makes sense but like the easy guess the
people that um i know well and trying to
now branch into other areas of
successful people and unique
entrepreneurs that maybe aren't the most
tech savvy or maybe aren't in the
industries that i've really highlighted
uh there are other people that are
successful and i think that that's
always kind of a little bit scary is
going after these really you know big
interesting unique interviews for
example uh later on
actually in january i'm having tucker
max on the show who wrote i hope they
serve beer in hell and he's a very
controversial author yes and and that's
gonna be those are the types of things
that excite me though so it's scary and
exciting at the same time i'm i'm trying
to go after just more unique interesting
guests and i think that's the key thing
that i i want to continue to do
and we have to ask how did you get seth
on the show and how soon after you
started the show did you actually land
him as a guest yeah good question and so
the guest thing and there's a lot of
people that love to do interviews and i
think interviews can be one of the most
amazing things that you can do and and i
evolved and the way i started it when i
first started doing interviews i started
with people i knew
just from a networking event or just
randomly or whatever it may be so i kind
of started smaller with people i knew
and then slowly built up
uh kind of courage to continue to ask
people to come on as the platform
started to build
and
seth was an interesting case because i
think i got like seven or eight no's
from seth before i got a yes no
um and the reason wasn't
him saying david go away you're terrible
uh maybe that's what he was thinking but
he didn't put that he
it was more that he's he's a busy guy
and
and he just didn't have time at the time
it was always david i'm very flattered i
don't have time dave and i'm very
flattered i don't have time and then i
thought to myself oh when is seth godin
gonna have time
and then i said you know what he's got a
new book coming out and if i know seth
godin or if i know people when you have
a book or when you have a replace book
with anything so product service new
show new monkey dog whatever it is
something that you want to talk about
suddenly the most inaccessible people
become very accessible and so once i
knew lynchpin was coming out from seth
godin i reached back i said hey seth i
know i'm over seven here but um you got
the new book coming out here's kind of
you know the audience for our show i
think would be pretty ravenous about it
would you love to come on and then he
was like let's do it and it's funny
there's a tendency to give up you know
when someone says no oh sure and i think
that some of my best interviews took a
while to get uh tim ferriss took two
years oh wow it's him ferris you know
for and i got the exclusive to break his
book um show the book for the very first
time now he's done a million interviews
but you know there but it takes
persistence and i think that this is a
lesson for any entrepreneur filmmaker
whatever you're doing i mean you're
gonna run into resistance i mean that
lizard brain either in your own brain or
or someone else being the lizard there's
always that resistance out there and if
you don't love it and if you don't
really believe in it and if you don't
really want to move forward it's very
easy to quit or give up or say i'm not
good enough or i can't do this and go on
to something else or do something safe
and i think that it's the people that
seem to be the most successful are the
ones that just are like no this is what
i'm going to keep moving it forward i'm
going to keep moving it forward no
matter what it takes no matter how many
knows and that's i think what makes the
difference in success david now karen
karen is the one that where she
discovered your show you know she was on
twitter and she saw the rise to the top
and you know and i've been in one of
these places where i've been so busy and
she keeps telling me david you got to
listen to the you got to see the rise to
the top and
and it hasn't been until this week where
you know and doing preparation for for
this interview
where i've just fallen in love with what
you have going on at the risethetop.com
um it's really it's it's like you know
you have this incredible archive you
know this the archives go on and on and
it's just like
a little kid on christmas morning every
morning
to gather all the knowledge and
information that you have there um
and along those lines i'm curious do you
go back and listen to your own shows
i mean do you continue to learn you know
weeks months later
by by going back and re-watching some of
your own shows yeah absolutely i think i
i'd like to do it even more too uh than
i do i i like to go back um you know
sometimes especially if things are
referenced and you can watch a lot of
things emerge and change because because
realize that this show started
differently i mean it started on a the
local abc station in st louis
and it's evolved so much so quickly and
i look back for many things i look back
one to learn i look back to watch myself
i i'm i'm always my harshest critic as
with many of us so i look back and i say
oh that was that was stupid or or what
are you doing or why why why are you you
know why'd you spill that coffee on
yourself again or whatever it was um but
i think that there there is a constant
learning experience with it you know i
always tell the story when i did my
first show which was a tv show so i i
had no experience and next thing i know
i'm thrown in front of eight cameras
doing a doing a um a tv show a pilot no
idea what i was doing i think it took
nine hours to shoot 30 minutes let's
just say back then and i wha i look at
that
often to one laugh at myself and two to
see how far things have progressed
because i had it i had a a zest to do it
but i didn't have the experience and so
when i was up there i was like spray
tanned and hair gelled i mean you have
no idea bad
very very very bad lots of hair gel lots
of spray tan
and i look at i'm like who's that guy
and i think that
you get practice when you do a show
where you start to get more and more
comfortable in your own skin and being
yourself and saying hey this is me on
and off the camera i'm not going to try
to act like a tv person would or how
a certain person would i'm going to act
like how i act and as soon as i start to
do that i think that's been a huge
turning point as well with it
let's talk about what seth godin said on
your show about entrepreneurs being
subject to criticism and being sort of
very polarizing figures and i use susie
orman as an example i love susie but i
realize
there can be a lot of controversy around
her and she was interviewed recently on
a show called talk stoop with cat
greenleaf and cat asked her what do you
say to people who may say you're
egotistical and you're not humble or
grateful for your success and susie said
you know what i really don't care what
people think about me you know should i
be ashamed that i'm an incredibly
wealthy woman that i'm attractive and
powerful nope because i earned these
things and she just she said i own this
you know and so tying this back to what
seth godin said
about criticism and i think this falls
prey also to filmmakers putting yourself
out there you are
especially on the internet you're you're
risking being criticized and in now in
the light of cyber bullying and and
group hate how do you how do you think
this fear holds a lot of people back and
has it ever affected you
yeah so that's a absolutely fantastic
question because i think it's something
that's relevant to a lot of people i
mean you know
i would be very much lying if i said and
and i would disagree with anyone that
probably says this when they say that
they they just
are
you know they don't they could care less
if they hear something negative you know
and we all say that because then you're
like then less people say something
negative if they if they
if they if they know we really care less
are they without if we say we don't care
maybe less people will say it right
right that's that's one of the classic
things and you know what i've gotten
negative stuff i've i've seen you know
i am lucky that it's been few and far
between but you know i i've gotten you
know stupid emails from people and and
people with certain things and i
certainly understand that people are
entitled to their opinion and i i see it
in two different categories and this is
the way that i think people that are
thinking about putting stuff out there
whether it's a film or whatever you've
got the
the relevant criticizer
who in many cases
has a good point
right and they're civil and they're not
a name caller and they just maybe
disagree with you
and in that case that's great you know
that's a person that you can engage in a
conversation with and you're not gonna
start throwing shoes at them or whatever
it may be
but on the other hand unfortunately a
lot of things on the internet or what i
call the negabot
and a lot of people call these people
the trolls i'll call them the negabot
because the negabot wakes up when it's
85 and sunny and complains that's not
86.
the megabot the megabot will find the
worst in any situation you know they
want a million dollars why isn't it a
million and two or they have to pay a
bunch of taxes or whatever the negabot
is a sad sad sad little person that is
going to try to rip down people uh
because they're unhappy with themselves
and a lot of times these people are
anonymous and and they try to sneak in
there and they try to throw the jab at
the back your head and they run away and
my number one piece of advice with these
people is you can't worry about it sure
it might affect you and piss you off for
a little bit it's one of those classic
things you get a hundred mean or 100
nice comments and one mean one you
remember the mean one but i think that
what i've noticed is you just have to
realize that that's part of the game and
actually turn it on the flip side and
say hey you know what negatives are so
far between the more that i'm getting
that means there's probably more
positive people out there that are
seeing this as well so while the
negatives might be louder at least
you're eliciting emotional response from
someone so my advice for people that are
willing to stick themselves out there
you have to grow that thicker skin it's
not worth getting into a fight with
people it's it's i think the high ground
is a great place to be i've never taken
a troll and been like oh yeah your
mother you know or something
a lot of times i write out something
really really mean and then i read it
out loud and then i just delete it that
makes me feel really good and then i
just and then i just don't say anything
so i think it's part of the game it's
part of any um entrepreneurial artist
that's gonna put anything out there
you're gonna get some people on the
negative but don't let that stop moving
you forward you take the abe lincoln
approach you write the letter but don't
send it yes right i got some funny
letters
let's talk about uh perceived value when
something is free i think there are two
schools of thought on this that
merely giving a product or service away
for free somehow diminishes its value
and the other the other school of
thought falls into that whole kind of
thank you economy thing where if you
give something away for free that
hopefully you will receive benefit later
on
why do you give your show away for free
because it most certainly has extreme
value
yeah you know i don't know i should
probably charge a million dollars no i
you know
it's funny this is the classic thing and
i've read a lot about it i've studied a
lot about it and and i and you know
things might change in the future um i
am a big believer in the thank you
uh economy
with a twist
being that you have to have some way of
making money otherwise you have a hobby
my grandpa used to always say that to me
i'd have these like little crazy stuff
i'd come to him with and he said that
looks like a hobby that looks like a
hobby there has to be revenue coming
from somewhere and the reason that i do
it right now
is that you know i think when stuff is
free
um
you know it can also spread faster when
it's not behind walls
you can you can get it out there and
people can share it without people you
know it's like that compounding
marketing effect of people sharing stuff
if it's really good and it's hard to
share stuff that's behind a wall or
behind some kind of membership program
however that being said i'm not against
that model i know i've interviewed a lot
of people that have had a lot of success
with that model might even be something
i do in the future who knows but what
i've noticed that i love doing is the
triangle
and you guys are similar with this as
well so the triangle is this that i have
my community
and its sponsors that are paying for
ford to be mentioned in the rise
episodes
and then i deliver the guests and
content free and so people are getting
it free it's the classic media model um
but there's sponsorships and and
promotions that are involved that i do
before the episodes and it's something
that i've played with tweaked mess with
messed up had success had failures with
i'm always playing with the sponsorship
model uh but it's something that has
worked well for us right now so there
isn't necessarily a need to to go a
different route at the moment but i
think that the lesson here is that
the more you give away i think the
better as long as you have something
that people pay for at some point and i
think that we often miss that little
note that there has to be some kind of
payment somewhere you know for me
the book believe it or not karen was the
first thing that i promoted directly to
my community that i created for uh for
sale now granted it's 24.95 it's not you
know a million dollars but what was
interesting was that they were very
receptive to it um because i'd never
asked for anything before
and so as soon as i put the book out it
went right into the top three marketing
books on amazon right next to uh tipping
point and new rules of marketing and pr
and i think that that was a testament of
that when you're not trying to sell
people all the time and instead the
sales are occasional on very high
quality stuff i think people um have
more of a susceptibility to purchasing
it and i think that's something that
i've also seen through some other
interviews with people um you know
social media examiner a huge website
went from zero to about two million in
revenue in about a year which is scary
and they only sell stuff twice a year
they sell these online seminars i'm
actually participating in one coming up
and you know it's a 300 ticket for an
online seminar and they've made like two
million dollars in two years from these
online seminars without selling anything
else on a daily basis the rest of what
they do is free awesome content so i
think there's something there
there's just so much to get at i i love
everything you're saying david one thing
i do want to cover is something that you
sort of share in common with so many
filmmakers that that you know that we
talk to and sort of this issue that that
we're dealing with
um and the thing is this is is you know
filmmakers who spend all their money on
their films and then they have no money
left over for distribute distribution
and marketing and and this sort of you
sort of fell into this trap with your tv
show in the early beginnings where
you put all your money into the
production and then you had no way to
market it um
so what what did you do you know how how
how did you sort of get yourself out of
that that trap there yeah so yeah
exactly you know i took my bar mitzvah
money from when i was 13
and i took my i took some money that i
was able to raise from some sponsors
which is you know the equivalent of what
filmmakers do right um and i i was able
to pull this money together to get the
show going for the first year
and that was it there was no more money
for anything what so whatsoever and so i
had to sit down and say okay what can i
do you know because the station was
coming to me and saying hey you got to
buy all these ads and you know buy a
billboard and put your face on it lord
forbid and
all these kind of things that they could
do but it all cost a lot of money and i
said well i don't have that money and
they said well your show's not going to
be a success and i said i think i can
figure out some ways to do it
so what i really did to build the
audience in the community uh at the
beginning here because realize i was
getting people to watch traditional tv
at this point so it was getting people
offline um is i started
really using facebook and twitter at the
time to really start building a
community i used facebook and twitter
to start tracking down people in the
industry
and i started tracking down um you know
be it guests be it people that that that
were interested in entrepreneurship um
you know i was aggressive networking
online that's what i use it for i want
to introduce myself to people i want to
say here's a show check it out we'd love
to hear your thoughts it's going to help
you with your business um whatever it
may be and i use a combination of social
media on one hand
there's gonna be many hands here not two
hands by the way uh social media uh then
i did a huge local pr i didn't i didn't
know anything about pr by the way so
it's not like i was i knew how to write
a press release or whatever what i did
was i got my butt out from behind my
computer and started going to events
where i knew press was going to be at i
just walk right up to him and introduce
myself oh nice and say hey i'm david i'm
doing a new show this is it um you know
people like a new story you know and i
was a young entrepreneur and so yeah
they like a young new story though i
started to really try to make friends
with the press because that was again a
low-cost option right and the third
thing that i did that i think was
interesting was i started inviting
people to events in st louis so i
started hosting dinners the first year
they weren't money makers or anything
but it got people
away from the computers and it was able
to kind of expand the network um that i
was starting to create you know i got to
meet people i'd never met but i
connected to online i got to meet people
offline i never met and then connect
with them later online and so it was
just getting out there and hustling and
just being a ferocious relationship
builder and networker and
the ratings on the show went through the
roof and the network you know i didn't
even tell them what i did
they just couldn't understand why there
was people watching the show with no
advertising paid for and i think the
lesson from this was that
the speed that i can move at was fast
because i was nimble and small and
excited and passionate um but it was
also just like the things i write about
in my book it takes time and effort and
i think that's one of the key things you
have to sit down and say what do i what
can i what can i invest more of right
now can i invest more money or can i
invest more time and effort and for me
it was time and effort and it paid off
quite well and i think it's something
that that that kind of um is the great
equalizer no matter what your budget is
and what was that breakthrough kind of
aha moment when you said you know what
i'm doing the show i'm out there
interacting with people wow i'm on to
something here this thing is growing
faster than i can kind of stop it
yeah you know i think when
i think
i don't know if there was an individual
tipping point as as opposed to
it was just sort of like things happen
where we're sort of like when you look
at a stock lightning bolt you know like
when someone represents the stock market
and it goes like dips and then it goes
up and then it kind of keeps going but
it but overall it goes up you know and i
think that you know i started then
posting the episodes online i'd get zero
comments zero comments my dad commented
zero comments zero comments and then you
know i think there were points where
people started to engage a little bit
with it and it kind of fused word of
mouth but i think that a big thing with
it was consistent effort it was
consistently on twitter consistently on
facebook consistently doing my best to
answer every single email that came in
um you know really kind of getting
personal with it um just slowly started
to build it i mean we just did the data
on it uh this year and this in 2010
the show was either watched or
downloaded without tradition forget
traditional media no traditional media
here so all online mobile phones itunes
etc um the show was listened to or
downloaded 3.5 million times in 2010. oh
my gosh wow and and you know
it was a building block it was it didn't
go from 10 to 3.5 it didn't go from zero
it went from like zero to one
person one to two people and and that's
how it snowballed and you know it's
lonely at the beginning too i mean it
was sitting there saying i think this is
pretty decent i want more people to
watch what can i do and i think it was
just continuing to move forward and just
interact with more people and and
introduce myself to more media and more
bloggers and form better relationships
and i think the success is really with
the network on the topic of over valuing
your overvaluing your product or service
um in a recent recent example of this in
movie terms
is the film how do you know the latest
movie by james l brooks starring jack
nicholson and reese witherspoon
um they spent 120 million dollars to
make this dramedy which is that's not
really usually a genre you're going to
spend that kind of money on um and it's
sort of tanked at the box office it's
earned 22 million to date um you know
this this happens in the film business
that happens in
um all you know businesses across the
board to the smaller entrepreneur
what do you say to an entrepreneur or
filmmaker who believes that they have
this this product this this film that's
going to change the world
um
you know how does overconfidence damage
things especially at the beginning of a
venture
yeah i think you know overconfidence can
you know there's there's points everyone
goes through disappointments um everyone
goes through
you know those men i've never talked to
anyone
i've yet to and i've done about 300
interviews that said you know what i had
this plan i had this idea and everything
went to plan and it was great and now
i'm riding off into the sunset into my
little little hut or whatever i've yet
to hear anyone where it all goes
smoothly and i think that you know
expectations are tough thing i mean i i
expected things to go even you know i'm
i'm an impatient entrepreneur i expected
things to go even faster than they did
and i think that there you have to be
mentally tough um and think forward as
opposed to going backward
and saying hey i've got five viewers
today i need six tomorrow
but i think what's interesting about
that david is with new media right is
that you look at how
cheaply things can be done now in
different areas i think filmmaking is an
interesting industry with that where you
know this because they're overhead and
because they're marketing and because
all those things were so expensive 22
million dollars is a huge disappointment
but i know plenty of people
that on the other hand 22 million
dollars would be a massive win so
everything is is relative when it comes
to this kind of thing and and i think
you know for me for example by cutting
out the middle man and being able to do
this entire show uh with my own team by
myself as opposed to relying on a
network or other people um
you get to reap the benefits of it i
think that's a that's one of the
interesting things about it and i think
that um you know taking everything every
punch and jab as a learning lesson that
can either propel you forward or hold
you back but i think that you want to
start i've always loved that be the
underdog the person that's saying it's
going to be okay it's going to be ah
even if i really believe in it and i try
to exceed those expectations so i don't
set up for failure you know it seems
like oftentimes it's it's kind of the
gurus and experts that you know they
offer us kind of hope and promise and
all that that we can succeed with their
principles but at the end of the day
business is hard you know making films
that's a hard thing it's a hard time to
make a living and it it seems like
sometimes the only people making money
in all of this
are the gurus and the experts kind of
selling us this dream so do the the
principles from your book really make
people money
yes absolutely and you know and i'll
tell you why that's a great question
because i'm sort of anti-guru and
actually when i hear that word it makes
me want to vomit in my mouth a little
bit um but because
i i
that's why i interview the type of
people that i do on my show i want to
interview people that are doers
you know and can talk about it of course
right but as opposed to the person that
comes in with the three points the seven
points the uh
the you know whatever the points are and
they they're they made their life by
teaching you how to turn your business
into five to seven points to explain to
people or whatever right that that's
that's the classic thing that we always
see
and what i'd argue is that um
you know i've done it i started with a
budget of very little dollars trying to
compete against giants and have turned
this now into an extremely profitable
business
um you know as an independent
talk show creator
i you know i've done it from scratch so
i know it works and more than that
the people that have really gained these
audiences and fan bases online that i
mentioned the book ranging from gary
vaynerchuk to chris brogan to the
millionaire matchmaker patty stanger and
everyone in between they are people that
have done it as well and i think that we
can as opposed to learning from someone
telling you how to do it or you know
these are the things you need to do
i think that the best strength is
inspiration hearing from people that
have done it what they've learned and so
that you can do it in your own way it's
not about copying it's not about
emulating per se but it's about learning
and applying a lot of the lessons and
the takeaways so i've seen it i've got
hundreds and hundreds of examples of
people that um unbeknownst to them we're
building businesses smarter faster
cheaper as opposed to dumber slower
expensive and i pulled a lot of those
stories together because the last thing
we wanted was a fluffy bunny running
around saying this may or may not work
you know in one of the interviews that
you know we looked at you mentioned that
you are generating a six-figure income
um and so your book that you just
mentioned um just launched less than a
month ago so we're not sure how much of
um the equation that makes up um you've
removed banner ads from your site
um
you know it and then so i mean as you
often do with your guests on your show
can you kind of give us an idea of where
the buckets are for you where's all this
revenue coming in yeah one of my
favorite questions too that i love
asking this to guess so i'll have to
answer it myself take my own medicine uh
you know so here's what we do and and by
the way this is always evolving like
every year it's different so i'll give
you the snapshot of what we're doing uh
in in 2011. so um
anyone that has written a book will tell
you a book is not a money maker
what whatsoever
um you know unless you're one of the
harry potter or whatever um a book is an
idea that you know you're trying to
spread and it's something that helps
people and also builds your platform in
many cases and allows you to do other
things if that makes sense on a personal
level so a book deal isn't you know i
got a very generous actually advanced
for my book but um it's one of the many
buckets so sponsorships are are the
number one bucket um right now and what
i do is i do like the old school radio
like you guys do right and before each
episode of rise uh this year i'm gonna
have uh three sponsors
on and i talk about them and i show
their website and i link it up in the
show notes so we syndicate that out and
now we have the audience to really be
able to monetize that pretty well um so
that's it i mean that that is the
sponsorship opportunity that we're
offering in 2011 um because trust me
i've been over complicated with this in
the past and that's been that's been
a good lesson over complicated never
works we're selling three sponsorships
in front of each episode um that is
going to generate a lot of income in
2011. another bucket for me um is i do
speaking and i do a little bit of side
consulting if you will i was i was hired
actually recently by google to do
consulting which i have never done
consulting so this has been fun
and uh it's nice to start with a big
company like google um you know it for
me speaking and consulting is fun i love
doing the interviews that's my favorite
thing to do but it's something that i i
also do that makes that makes revenue um
and the other thing i would fall into
the categories of other and those are i
always look for opportunities for
projects i i try to at least keep some
time open and keep my eyes and ears open
for projects that i find interesting
that i can take on that might be um of
of benefit or just be fun and you know
it might be like i really want to do
something in film i just don't know what
it's going to be in the future i think
that that could fall in there and i also
when you have a show you start to get
access to super interesting people and
and one of those types of access that
i'm starting to get involved in is
people that invest in early-stage
companies and i'm going to be doing a
little bit of that as well to uh
increase revenue so a lot of different
buckets i'm a big believer in leverage
i'm a big reliever in multiple streams
of income so that's kind of uh the
inside look at that that's a few that
people don't know about
we're going to continue watching your
show we had about 40 questions to ask
you and we just got to a fraction of
them yeah we'd love to keep going um
it's a 50-minute show but we want to
wish you the best
and uh i know we'll hear more from you
i know oh absolutely guys an absolute
pleasure for having me on have me back
any time we'll try to cut the other 40.
you know we'll do a 140 part interview
series
a little tedious for everyone but uh you
know i i appreciate it and you know what
i love what you guys are doing i think
this is an awesome show and it's great
to see um two people that love a
community and that that's my number one
message that i have for everyone all the
time is that when you focus not on
yourself but when you focus on you know
entertaining educating and inspiring a
community of people that's when the
magic happens for yourself as well it's
one of those those interesting cycles
and circles and i think you guys are
doing it thank you very much
yeah i think he said it better than
either you or i could yeah
you know and it's such a great way to
start off our new year
you know with this theme of rising to
the top um we thank you so much david
for taking time out of your busy
schedule and we wish you the best we're
going to continue to follow you yes we
will we've been speaking with david
siteman garland of the web show and
website the rise to the top and author
of the new book smarter faster cheaper
for more on david please visit
therisetothetop.com on twitter at the
rise to the top on facebook at
davidgarland and also
smarterfastercheaper.com
for more on his book and you can also
find it wherever books are sold so again
thank you david for kicking off the 2011
film courage season and we're thrilled
that you are our first guest of the year
and david siteman garland is most
certainly someone to watch for for more
to watch for and listen for please join
us on the next film courage where we
will feature danny mantis of no bull
script consulting also hugs and kisses
to ronan rosner tech engineer who has
most certainly moved us in the right
direction for 2010 we appreciate
his help every week getting the show to
sound great and also for
buildingfilmcourage.com and until next
sunday have a great week